I think there's a few important things
that patients need to do in order to
prevent a recurrence the first thing is
to really manage you know your own
follow-up appointments I think there's a
few of us that were surprised that
doctors don't send that little card out
in the mail to remind you like a dentist
used to do to remind you of those
follow-up appointments it's your
responsibility to manage those and
you've got several doctors appointments
to follow up depending on the type of
treatment for me I had to follow up with
my surgeon an oncologist my radiologist
and for a while first year of my plastic
surgeon so there were several
appointments that I needed to manage and
monitor and that is critical that you
stay on top of that they're not going to
call and remind you it doesn't happen
and so it's your responsibility I also
believe that changing your lifestyle is
important this is a new lifestyle you
have had cancer it's over you're done we
are here starts to go back and you start
to feel better and healthy and your life
moves on but at the end of the day you
had cancer and it's now lifestyle that
you need to monitor and manage that
means you know looking at your diet and
eating healthy foods there's been a big
link to be kept being having extra
weight and and fat in the diet and on
your body linking with cancer so being
healthy and eating well exercise and
just being very cognizant of how your
you feel on a day-to-day basis how your
body feels and recognizing any potential
symptoms to you know
make that phone call if there's any
concern well I'll tell you I definitely
treated this cancer a little differently
than the first one I knew to take care
of myself I knew to stay positive I need
a wait to find out all the information
when I went to see my doctors before I
panicked before I went to the website so
i implemented everything that I you know
from experience I I did exactly what I
tell everybody else to do I followed the
rules i called my insurance insurance
carrier I made sure to have all my
questions ready before and prepare
before my doctor's appointments I had
all my paperwork in my slides pathology
report I asked all the questions and had
several opinions before we went ahead
and made the final decision of the
treatment that I would take on so and
even going through the process I hate to
say it but a variant cancer I thought
you know it had breast cancer I know
what the surgery is going to be like
I've had that I've you know I've I've
had chemotherapy well it was about ten
times harder with the surgery and the
chemo that was a bit of a surprise but
the process remained exactly how I knew
to get through it and I was able to stay
positive and keep my family from
panicking and my friends from panicking
which is unfortunately one of the jobs
that are not sometimes we end up taking
on is keeping everybody else calm and
your friends and families start to
really panic but I was very lucky I got
again an opportunity to see some
wonderful doctors I had I what else I
have my cancer 101 planner and I just
before I was about to go to pressed is
to prepare this planner for people with
breast cancer I had to stop the process
we read in
editing and about to send it to the
printer and I grabbed the prototype and
I used it and though it was designed for
people with breast cancer I was the
organizer component that really got me
through the process and was able to keep
me calm and focused about my next steps
I had a place to put all my appointments
my notes my business cards and it really
helped my mother who was flew in from
Chicago to be with me you know as a
mother she was just devastated so I
think the planner really kept us both
organized and everything all our notes
were in one place so we could share this
book together